one story about your dad the the bet the
bet involving your brother do you know
the story I mean the the bicycle yes I
like the moto kaa another way my dad did
great business our rings are so similar
you get laid a gap used by Hollywood
star take this out sit back enjoy yeah
it's a great so my dad had a ranch would
time with his friends they've been deer
hunting all day and it's late at night
they're sitting out the barn drinking
this stuff and fella said the subject
comes up how high everybody can pee you
know how high all right and he's got
this buddy named Jim who's about six
foot six and they're playing cards
looking around my dad see just old BMX
bikes and we couldn't afford BMX bike
now my middle brother did wanting to be
a mex motorcycle but we couldn't afford
it there's this old CRX 80 over there
and dad says or you know Jim my son he
could pee over your head on the wall
and you know there's no way you can do
that and he goes hey Ken I'll bet y'all
puppet up at the motor bike on it the
guy goes out there's no way I'm six foot
six pop gets in the car drives an hour
and half back into town wakes my 12 year
old brother up an exciting ride gets
them out of bed what you got to do and
you get woke up in Illinois Jacquet you
gotta pee right my dad says no no no get
in the car don't have a sip on this beer
go ahead and work about to go we're
about to go get yourself a motorcycle
buddy so it fit there's Tyler they write
an hour and a half back you're back at
four in the morning and brings my
brother in the barn
they put Jim up against the wall Jim
marks the market six foot six and my dad
said go ahead boy
my foot put the CRX 100 in the back of
the truck got on my dad my brother's
first motorcycle ran or near if you'd
like to see even more stuff like that
that hit subscribe Hotel the free world
but I know what I do in that situation